tucker carlson's show on fox news
is a major
catalyst
of disinformation
and his ratings are really good
so
what is he doing now
he's going further down the conspiracy
rabbit hole to the point that you can't
even understand what he's saying this is
a really common characteristic among
charlatans among pseudoscience purveyors
and others at a certain point the things
they say no longer make sense to anyone
even their followers
but that's okay because their followers
assume
it must make sense to someone so i'm
going to just go with it if you look
back at jim jones from the people's
temple this is the guy who got
his followers to drink cyanide-laced
kool-aid and kill themselves
his so-called teachings over time would
make less and less sense to his
followers
and some of them would be sort of
conflicted
but the fact that it made no sense
became a source of his power he must
really be telling us some high-level
stuff here i had the good sense to start
following him i'm not understanding what
he's saying but it must really be
important stuff
alex jones his conspiracy theories
became and have become increasingly
unintelligible so anyway here's
basically an alex jones type conspiracy
theory
from tucker carlson related to the white
house looking set that the biden
administration used for joe biden's
third vaccine dose look at all of the
things
that
tucker carlson infers from the fact that
the white house has like a set that
looks like one room from the white house
take a look at this and keep them
informed of international incidents
instead
they are in some cases freelancing to
crush anyone who opposes their power
mike flynn for example he was briefly
the national security adviser in the
trump administration what we learned
from the destruction of mike flynn
really was that sure you can elect
donald trump president but does he
really run the executive branch of
government sorry and i'm realizing i
started this too late we're getting to
mike flynn in a moment but let's let's
pick it up at the beginning take a look
at the latest example these are pictures
of a fake white house set that the buy
administration has for some reason
constructed across the street from the
actual white house it's in an auditorium
at the eisenhower executive office
building why go to the trouble they
already have a white house
well stephen miller spent the last four
years in the white house as an adviser
to trump and here's his explanation for
it because he would know quote the
reason biden uses this bizarre virtual
set for televised meetings is not an
actual room like the east room the
cabinet the oval the roosevelt sit room
etc a lot of rooms the reason he does
this is because it allows him to read a
script directly from a face on monitor
and without teleprompter glass that can
be seen on camera so this this is
actually quite silly because if that was
the concern you could just do that by
setting up a different camera angle in
any of the rooms tucker mentioned like
even at its at its core it doesn't even
pass the sniff test
oh
now we can't verify that that's true but
it certainly sounds right well maybe joe
biden can't speak from the oval office
because he's not sure what to say so he
has to read it all here
so that raises a much deeper question
the question is not is joe biden
mentally impaired obviously he is and
again we're not going to gloat over it
but a much more important question for
the rest of us is if he's not running
the government
then who is
that's a real question
clearly the fbi the doj and the military
already acting independently of the
elected president of the united states
as you just saw they don't even keep
them informed of international incidents
instead
they are in some cases freelancing to
crush anyone who opposes their power
okay so
it's starting to get very very
conspiratorial and then just to show you
like how far this all goes here's one
one more example
here's tucker's preview of an interview
with trump's former national security
adviser michael flynn
and he's talking about deep state
conspiracy theories
i think that with a long interview with
mike flynn it's coming out monday and he
told us what is really obvious to
everyone who watches
an unelected group within washington
effectively runs the country without
reference to voters here's his
assessment
we have two separate governments we have
the one that actually gets elected and
goes into office
and then you have a government
inside of washington dc that operates
under no rules uh no authorities other
than their own or who's ever in charge
of that sounds like that government was
still controlled by barack obama yeah
and and i would say that that's that uh
to a degree is is what we're operating
with today
by the way mike flynn is not some
internet celebrity or conservative
activist he was a three-star general
who became a complete and total lunatic
once he started working for trump or
before and we just didn't notice an
intelligence agency was the number two
guy for all american intelligence he
spent his entire life working in the
federal government and succeeding at
that so he knows what he's talking about
he is a reliable guide to how the
government actually works
our whole conversation with mike flynn
by the way yeah he could not be a less
reliable guide as to how the government
works mike flynn seems to have had
something happen that has made him
completely delusional about even the
basic facts of how the world works so
this is a really they're basically
talking about like an obama run deep
state of some kind and this has many
many iterations this is a family of
conspiracies much studied significant
amount of literature on it
sometimes it's called deep state it's a
shadow government of some kind
sometimes you call it the deep state
sometimes it's the freemasons sometimes
it's the jews sometimes it's the vatican
could be the trilateral commission the
illuminati the bilderbergs it it's it's
there's a bunch of versions of it and
this seems to be
what tucker carlson's audience now wants
so when we talk about oan and newsmax
are well beyond fox news in terms of
what they're willing to put on air yeah
it's true in a way
and yet look at what's happening on
tucker's show lately and then in
addition when we say well you've got
msnbc which is left and fox news which
is right sure they're both corporate
media networks with different editorial
bents
but there is nothing on msnbc that is
equivalent to this
uh so this seems to be what tucker's
audience wants and fox news seems to be
gleefully promoting it and and signal
boosting and accepting it and again i
think it's because of the financial
incentives even though there have been
advertiser troubles with tucker
uh and his show
the ratings are still there
and overall this is a good show for fox
news's business model we're gonna have
more of this on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is shaker and spoon
the monthly cocktail subscription box
that delivers the ingredients and
recipes for amazing craft cocktails
right to your door i use shaker and
spoon to make cocktails at home always
fun the last one i made was citrus
paradisi nice combination of vodka tonic
lime green tea and rose nothing better
than rose you open the box everything
you need is right there the recipe card
all the ingredients except for the
alcohol it's great because they always
have ingredients that are really high
quality and hard to find the
instructions are easy so my cocktails
always turn out great even though i
don't know anything about mixing drinks
but you learn a lot of new things about
cocktails using shaker and spoon which i
love about it opening up your shaker and
spoonbox is a great way to spend a night
in and you'll get 20 off when you use
promo code pacman at checkout go to
shakerandspoon.com
pacman the link is down below